wenn wir ein prozent aller gebäude
jährlich energetisch sanieren ist für
die erreichung der klimaziele aber vier
prozent sein müssten dann ist das a oder
b sehr dumm oder c scheiße
[Musik]
was hat mehr zur erreichung der
klimaziele beigetragen
die große koalition b corona oder c
dass markus söder täglich bäume umarmt
naja der markus söder ist ehrlicherweise
schon guter faktor auch für das thema
klima ziele der nimmt das wirklich ernst
er macht nicht nur mit content und die
große koalition macht auch so corinna
gut dass sie das sagen habe ich nicht
also jetzt kurzfristig auf die die
emissionen sind ja sieben prozent runter
gegangen durch bewohner aber kann ich
das so festhalten dass wir gerade gehört
habe dass karl lauterbach etwas
positives über corona gesagt hat nein
das war eine positive nebenwirkung aber
keine haupt okay wofür steht 10h bei der
10h regel die entfernung zur nächsten
siedlung muss der zehnfachen höhe des
windrades entsprechen oder b ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha
weil wir die umwelt auslachen und ist
auch sinn vorher also die 10a regelung
glaubt mal die sind das glaube ich nicht
werden ein positivbeispiel in bayern wo
die bürger vor ort direkt am windpark
beteiligt wurden mit einer rendite von
46 prozent
in den ersten jahren vielleicht auch was
für sie sind ja auch an aktien doch
durchaus mal interessiert ist
der bus der telekom also der abstand ist
einfach viel zu groß die zehn jahre ist
aus meiner sicht ein fehler und also
lässt flächen ungenutzt die optimal
geeignet während für die für die
windenergie ein fehler es richtig steht
auch in so der länge ja ja ist das
geschehen lange antwort ja ist das so
das ist kein witz vielleicht die antwort
auch einmal selber sagen sonst können
wir sie nicht ein sonst können sie nicht
ein
hahahaha
hhs war neunmal bitte ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha es war jetzt richtig war
richtig oder sehr gut
um welchen faktor hat die bundesanstalt
für geowissenschaften den infraschall
bei windrädern zu hoch berechnet also
erstmal zurück grün internet um welchen
faktor hat die bundesanstalt für
geowissenschaften den infraschall
windrädern zu hoch berechnet um den
faktor 0 ist schließlich die
bundesanstalt für geowissenschaften oder
b um den faktor 1000 bis 10.000 ich
schätze mal letzteres aber ich weiß es
nicht weil ich das gar nicht weiß
darf ich sowas sagen als politiker das
nicht weiß das ist ungewohnt normalspur
bild man dann rummel haben sie das noch
nicht gelernt dass man schwul bild ja
ich kann das auch aber jetzt wirbeln sie
doch mal googeln sie mal so sind die
grünen nicht regierungsfähig also ich
bitte sie also ich bin der meinung dass
man das erstmal komplett eruieren muss
und da müssen wir erst mal die
verschiedene meinung einholen
wo ist der infraschall am höchsten
der infraschall den anbrüllen dann kommt
der stadt zurück woher wissen sie dass
ich nehme das angaben bei windrädern b
bei trampolin oder c bei einer rede von
alice weiter arbeiten
es ist unerträglich dass ist im ganzen
gebäude zu spüren
diese diese negative situation kann
jeder die frage kann ich spontan und
also sicher beantwortet c bei einer rede
von alice weide
letzteres da ist geht richtig die
stimmung
wir sitzen ja da nie und da ist der
infra winter aber sowas von
wenn in deutschland pro jahr 100
millionen vögel durch glasscheiben
sterben und durch windräder bis zu
100000 was sollten wir dann verbieten a
windräder die fensterscheiben oder c
vögel
sehr sehr schwierige frage ich wähle
keine dieser antworten sie übrigens
katzen töten noch mehr tiere ganz
verbieten und ich habe spiele ich habe
eine schlimme katzenallergie ich habe
jetzt keine bild -zeitung schlagzeile
darzustellen in dieser die linke
wildkatzen töten katzen mörder hatten
wir müssen die energiewende sind
katzenberger etwas muss man so klar
sagen schön was haben sie gegen katzen
es sind solide tiergarten sind meine
lieblings haus
aber warum wollen sie dann alle
umbringen deswegen habe ich ja gesagt
wie ich weder a nach b sondern liegt die
krise also ich möchte dir gleich gar
nicht mehr reden als wer katzen hat
hören möchte was gehört zu den
kerngeschäften der deutschen bahn hätten
reparieren
ja jetzt wenn sie nicht unrealistisch
ist so ach so ja ok stehen bitte ich
bitte sie sind schon wieder in ihrer
fantasie wo abgedreht ist eine
schätzfrage wie viel co2 konnte man
einsparen wenn karl lauterbach nicht
dreimal die woche zum markus lanz
pendeln
ich glaube der macht das aber relativ
co2 schonend und nimmt meistens den zug
und meistens bleibt ja auch einfach da
in hamburg weil er am nächsten tag schon
wieder zu markus lang also insofern also
die größenordnung kann ich nicht
einschätzen aber das ist sicherlich also
mehr als fünf oder sechs haushalte
verbrauchen was schrumpft schneller die
polkappen b die umfragewerte der spd
dabei man muss sagen bei den polkappen
ist noch mehr substanz da zum schwimmen
muss ehrlicherweise ist das auch für die
gesamte menschheit noch wichtiger als
die sp ab nächster woche also geht es
bei der spd bei uns wieder bergauf wir
senden leider dann übernächste woche es
heißt es dann kurz hoch wie lange das
ist es schon wieder hat es sich eine
woche züge
was ist schwerer a die berechnung der
materie von schwarzen löchern mit hilfe
eines mathematik buchs der fünften
klasse oder b
die erfolgreiche stellung eines
förderantrags auf energetische sanierung
in den mühlen der deutschen bürokratie
letzteres natürlich wobei das mit den
schwarzen löchern ich bin der für
raumfahrt zuständig auch ein spannendes
alljährlich sind sie ja es die grünen
haben raumfahrtexperten tatsächlich ja
ich bin das ich bin nicht nur das
wirtschafts- und raumfahrt machen sie
sind ja wirklich ein exot in allen
belangen
ich habe schon mal sowas beantragt
trasse unter angerufen da muss jemand
kommen uns mehr erklären und der antrag
läuft seitdem nicht auf der baustelle
weiß nicht verstanden noch eine weitere
frage zur energetischen sanierung was
lässt sich als dämmmaterial perfekt
verwenden a nutzlose fb2 masken b das
geschredderte wahlprogramm der afd hand
lässt sich sehr gut verwenden also
wirklich haben sie dann vorrat da den
man nutzen kann direkt womit sein ich
mir aber momentan nicht minder
interessant waren sie heute noch nicht
am kotti oder meine maxime ist der nazis
aus dem bundestag und ich würde es gut
finden wenn sie überhaupt gar keine
programme mehr produzieren müssten also
ich wohne zur miete in dem sinne und da
es ist also durchaus sehr vorsichtig auf
und vollständig saniert ok also eine
bruchbude wie ich so nicht sagen sonst
kriege ich noch raus aber bei der
sanierung ist noch denkbar luft nach
oben alles denkbar aber sprechen wir
sogar das studio von markus lanz oder so
ich war auch selektiert ja wohl nicht
nicht ja ach so na gut die erfolgreiche
stellung eines förderantrags auf
energetische sanierung in den mühlen der
deutschen bürokratie ja das dauert zu
lange nicht irgendwie große verbots
orgien jetzt abfeiern und sagen wir
verbieten jetzt hier noch die letzte
ölheizung sondern förderanreize schaffen
die kanzlerin hat ja auch eine ölheizung
kellern im kanzleramt tatsächlich
ehrlich ja ist energetisch auf
fragwürdig sie müssen gehen
[Musik]
tja jetzt muss unser auto hier erst mal
eine halbe stunde aufladen was machen
wir denn jetzt
wir könnten noch all die lustigen
heute-show videos gucken stimmt und den
kanal abonnieren und alle videos licon
kommentieren alles das super das machen
wir jetzt ja scheiße akku leer scheiße
können internet